we can detect planets outside our solar
system by the gravitational effects that
these planets have on their stars small
planets like Earth weigh much less than
their star when those planets move in
their orbits the effect on the star is
very hard to see the force they exert on
each other is comparatively small so the
star barely moves as the planet orbits
around it large planets like Jupiter
have a greater gravitational influence
on their star but when the planets are
far away the effect is still fairly
small the planet and star are orbiting a
common center point but it's close to
the center of the star however we found
planets that are larger than Jupiter and
which orbit much closer to their star
than Jupiter is to our Sun the effect of
gravity is much stronger in these cases
with such large planets it's easier to
see that the planets gravity affects the
Stars motion and that the two orbit a
common center we can't see the star move
back and forth because the stars are
very very very very far away from us
instead we use the Doppler effect the
same effect that causes sound to change
pitch when its source moves when a
source of waves moves towards us we hear
it as higher-pitched when the wave
source moves away from us we hear a
lower pitch in terms of light frequency
that corresponds to light moving more
towards blue higher frequency or more
towards red lower frequency the effect
is small so we don't see it in our
day-to-day lives but we can detect it
with a spectrometer as the exoplanet
moves away from us the star comes
towards us so the light becomes ever so
slightly more blue on the other side of
the orbit as the star moves away from us
the light from the star becomes slightly
more red
the amount of shift the difference from
blue to red light tells us how fast the
star is moving that in turn tells us
whether we have a light planet a medium
planet or a heavy planet affecting the
movement of the star and that's the
wobble method that's true that's one
thing we don't have right in this is
it's not spinning okay are you ready
you